[Musique]
la fameuse pénurie mais dont tout le
monde parle c'est notre plus grand jeu
je voudrais qu'à travers nos centres
kursaal une amende environ une
cinquantaine d'employés
le chauffeur notamment au manque
également de mécaniciens de vie que de
l'eau mais on manque également de triage
tous
aurélia des conséquences catastrophiques
au niveau de l'économie et ça devrait
être l'enjeu numéro un des partis
fédéraux dans la lah pour dix ans en
section veut pas que ce soit
catastrophique faut s'organiser tout le
monde en parle parce qu'elles touchent
tout le monde partout la pénurie de
personnel est devenu l'ennemi numéro 1
des entrepreneurs surtout depuis la
pandémie
c'est du jamais vu manquer autant
d'employés et ce qui a fait aussi qu'on
a dû diminuer nos adversaires on est
presque plus voir les soirs et on s'est
positionné comme étant commerces fermés
dimanche geneviève gagnon possède 5
quincaillerie dans différentes régions
du québec en plus d'une entreprise de
fabrication de matériaux de construction
comme beaucoup d'employeurs elle juge
que la pcu devenu pcr eux est un frein à
l'emploi nous sert un impact direct et
ça va leur cv parce qu'ils ont ils
doivent envoyer leur cv
on n'est pas de retour d'appel on a des
retours d'appels on embauche présente
pour la première journée de travail
c'est très très c'est un problème un
avis partagé par le conseil du patronat
actuellement au québec plus de 128 mille
personnes sont encore sur le programme
de la paix ces erreurs au canada c'est
plus de huit cent quarante cinq mille
personnes qui sont encore dessous le
programme de l'apc c'est inconcevable
dans un contexte de relance économique
c'est vrai surtout pour les emplois
moins bien rémunérés les c'est loin
d'être la seule explication à la pénurie
de personnel les entreprises qui pensent
que ça va finir quand on veut couper la
pcu s'y trompe pas ce qu'il ya plus de
personnes dans plusieurs régions qui
prennent leur retraite que john qui
rentrent sur le marché du travail
les pressions pour augmenter les
salaires et améliorer les conditions de
travail seront donc très forte dans les
dix prochaines années ils ont ployé leur
devront s'adapter pour complètement
changé notre approche avec elle la
dynamique d'emploi des fois faut prendre
la personne en interne qui juste lui
offrir la formation sur les heures de
travail payées c'est ce genre de
nouvelles réalités lover laquelle on
n'aura pas le choix de migrer miser sur
la formation en milieu de travail c'est
le genre de programme dès que les partis
fédéraux pourraient offrir aux
entreprises en pleine campagne
électorale quelques plein de petites
actions qui pourraient être prises qui
nous aident viennent nous les
entrepreneurs des petites actions comme
favoriser la rétention ils embauchent
des personnes âgées sur le marché du
travail autre solution l'immigration on
va recruter à l'étranger notamment ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on sur laquelle
on travaille très fort une demande qui
revient d'un secteur à l'autre ricco va
est à la recherche de camionneurs et des
bois on ne peut contre qu'on respecte
avec les mines spect et sincèrement et
sa boussole un peu c'est contre le fait
qu'on adore moins de personnel il faut
aussi favoriser les femmes sur le marché
du travail ce soir trois personnes
personnes et ans à s'en défaire si on
veut engager la religion du tarn sont
pas de cov en garderie ou des places qui
peuvent pas se permettre de payer les
montants qui sont demandés
bref tout pour accompagner les
entreprises à investir pour faire face à
cette réalité
celle d'après la pandémie et si jacques
houde richard beaudoux raid au canada
montréal
[Musique]